make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back again with another installment
of our what-if series where we just make
up stories we make up the stories we
always wanted to see but Marvel and DC
have never written and in this video we
are looking at what would happen if
apocalypse expanded his search for
horsemen to the DC Universe so just to
lay some foundation on what the horsemen
of apocalypse are throughout the
thousands of years that apocalypse has
been alive he has repeatedly looked for
minions to do his bidding and then
assigns them roles similar to the
biblical Horsemen of Apocalypse death
war famine and pestilence now while
there have been several iterations of
apocalypse as horsemen each time he
either grants them powers or augments
any existing powers they already had so
I thought it would be interesting to
discuss the possibility of Apocalypse
looking into the DC Universe for his
next batch of horsemen and really there
isn't any criteria for someone to become
a horseman of apocalypse it's basically
whoever he wants he usually picks
mutants but not always so really the
only criteria that I'm looking at here
in choosing his horseman is what will
make for the most interesting story
which is basically what writers do now
it would be really easy for us to just
pick some already powerful characters
and make them even more powerful by
having apocalypse enhance their
abilities but there would always be
equally or more powerful characters that
would be able to take them down
so that got me thinking what if instead
of just having Apocalypse take on a
powerful character like Superman or
Darkseid we have him serve as a villain
for someone with no powers like Batman
so this story would start with
apocalypse discovering the DC Universe
and figuring out a way to get there
which he has so much technology that it
really wouldn't be that hard but he
could easily make some adjustments to
the portals that he has on kokoa
to allow him to travel through
dimensions and since apocalypse is not
the kind of guy to rush into anything
without a great deal of planning it
would make sense that he's been using
his portals to observe the goings-on in
the DC Universe and I think that it also
makes sense he would develop a
particular disdain for Batman if you
know about apocalypse at all you know
that he sees humans as genetically
inferior to mutants so to see a guy like
Batman who's just a normal guy routinely
defeating super-powered individuals
would probably just piss him off because
he doesn't really understand that Batman
comics so better than any other
character in DC so he's given as much
plot armor as he needs to win battles
that he has no business winning matter
fact I've bet apocalypse would come to
that conclusion that would make a great
reason for apocalypse to be pissed off
of that name right like but at that
point you think you just like attack the
writers instead of going after Batman
but regardless apocalypse decides to be
the one that will prove that Batman is
not all he's cracked up to be and so as
part of this surveillance of Batman
apocalypse has learned about his
relationship with his current and former
sidekicks and so he sets a plan in
motion that he believes will exploit the
emotional connection Batman has to his
protegees emotion being one of the many
elements of humanity that apocalypse
believes makes them less evolved than
himself so one by one apocalypse starts
hunting down Batman's former robbed
starting with Jason Todd now he finds
Jason operating his Red Hood taking down
some B or C list villain and afterwards
he's confronted by apocalypse who offers
him a chance to take his evolution to
the next step by agreeing to become one
of his horsemen now Red Hood predictably
tells him to go to hell and then he
shoots apocalypse which to his surprise
has no effect on him and so apocalypse
then proceeds to absolutely pummel Red
Hood beating him within an inch of his
life I did you the courtesy of asking
you to join my cause Jason apocalypse a
talent but it was never really up to you
and with that
apocalypse would bestow a new power upon
Red Hood which heals him and turns him
into the horseman of pestilence next
apocalypse sets his sights on Tim Drake
who's still going by Red Robin because
this is our universe and we don't have
to recognize the terrible name of Drake
well regardless Tim immediately
recognizes Jason and is shocked to see
what this unknown blue guy has done to
him and things play out much the same
way they did with Jason as Tim Drake is
able to put up no fight whatsoever
against apocalypse and is quickly
defeated and transformed into the
horseman of famine now as you might
expect we see apocalypse then move on to
night one who he makes into the horseman
war and finally he targets Damian Wayne
to become his final horseman this occurs
however as Damian is out fighting crime
with his father now because Batman has
no time to prepare for this encounter he
gets obliterated by apocalypse but
rather than killing Batman apocalypse
turns Damian into the horseman of death
in front of him and then issues a
warning
he tells Batman to take all the time he
needs to gather whatever technology his
money can buy and that he'll be waiting
whenever Batman feels up to the task of
facing him in the meantime however
apocalypse and his horsemen will conquer
Gotham City and Batman will have to
watch those he cares about the most
terrorized a city he loves and so after
delivering this warning to Batman
apocalypse in the horsemen teleport away
and so Batman goes back to the Batcave
to tend to his injuries and begin
formulating a plan to take down
apocalypse and save his family and he
does all the standard Batman stuff right
like upping his armor and weaponry games
so they doesn't get every bone and his
body broken immediately after engaging
apocalypse he doesn't wait long before
seeking him out as apocalypse is making
good on his promise to terrorize Gotham
City but when Batman shows up to battle
him rather than battling Batman directly
apocalypse sends his horsemen to attack
their former mentor he then tries to
reason with him but apocalypse has
control over his forcement seems to be
too strong for Batman to make any
inroads in this way and so he's forced
to retreat now back in the Batcave Bruce
makes calls to all the allies he can
think of that may be able to figure out
a way to defeat apocalypse no one has
any knowledge of apocalypse but that
man's allies rallied to his side to help
him defeat this new enemy and so the
next time Batman encounters apocalypse
he's not alone but is backed up by most
of the Justice League which makes the
fight with apocalypse far more even now
at one point the battle even turns in
the favor of the justice but apocalypse
senses that the tide is turning and
teleports Batman himself and his
horsemen away from the conflict and then
he responds surely you didn't think I
wouldn't know we can't we can't we have
to do we have to do the apocalypse voice
aah Gordon or Jacob whichever one of you
is editing this keep this in here I want
people to understand my my thought
process they have to know ok uh we have
to do the apocalypse voice right so so
like surely you didn't think I wouldn't
anticipate you bringing your friends and
for help I've been watching you for a
long time Batman and I know all of your
tricks that's that's like the that is
the lamest bat that's the lamest
apocalypse voice ever that we could
possibly do okay uh it has to be
something deep right something deep and
like just menacing right like menacing
surely you didn't think I wouldn't
anticipate you bringing your friends and
for help I don't know I can't do a
Batman voice I can't do an apocalypse
voice it doesn't work anyway apocalypse
tells Batman
for too long you've battled those who
are your betters and thought you could
use money to occupy a place on the
evolutionary ladder where you don't
belong but
in the world couldn't buy a fraction of
the scientific knowledge I possess know
that after you die your legacy will live
on in my horsemen that you trained
admirably but that will now reach
greater potential than you could ever
provide as they remain in my servitude
that's the most apocalypse thing to say
I just want to say that that's the life
that's like the most apocalypse
statement ever but Batman readies for
perhaps his last battle but apocalypse
is struck by a blast from an unseen
assailant as it turns out apocalypse has
brought them all to the Marvel Universe
and is now being attacked by the x-men
who have found out that he's using the
crack Owen portals for his own means
without knowledge of the mutant council
and so apocalypse turns his attention to
the contingent of x-men that have
attacked him and his horsemen engaged
them in battle
Batman would then ask the question where
are we and then in response apocalypse
would say we are on my world on cacoa
the nation for the genetically superior
you have no place here I wanted to savor
your death but it appears I will have to
dispatch you more quickly than I would
have liked and then Batman will respond
wait
send my son's home and I will serve you
in your battle here you said you've been
watching me and so you must know that as
good as they are I'm better now
apocalypse responds if I wanted you in
my service Batman I would force you into
it and then Batman responds maybe you
could but I saw the hesitation in their
eyes when they attack me your power over
them is strong but not absolute and my
resolve is stronger than theirs the only
way you can control me is if I come
willingly and you know how strong my
detective skills are I'll find your
replacement the best candidates you
could possibly find and so apocalypse
contemplates Batman's proposal for a
moment and then says very well I find
your terms agreeable but ready yourself
for your first test is at hand and with
that apocalypse opens a portal strips
his power from the Robins and then
flings them to the portal back to the DC
Universe
he then imbues Batman with his power and
names him his horsemen death and as we
see the x-men surround apocalypse and
his new minion that's where the issue
ends burger would happy he said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
we left a cliffhanger on our own I clip
on you guys an R in a story that we made
up
I'm a dick whatever he said guys are
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like I almost forgot what I was gonna
say and I will catch you all later
Bruce
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]